this is the opening scene of season two
of broad city Abbi and Ilana the show's
creators and best friend protagonists
are just trying to survive a chaotic
subway ride and the camera kind of stops
on these other two women who are
standing there with pepper sprayed eyes
that's Caroline Francky I write about
culture at box
I have watched and analyzed the show to
death like many of the best moments in
broad city the entire scene is super
surreal so the women probably wouldn't
stand out to a first-time viewer but if
you watch broad city religiously like we
do you'll immediately get the joke you
see those two women are a callback to a
moment in the first season when Abbi and
Ilana actually got pepper-sprayed
they're wearing the same clothes and
have the same devastated looking faces
Alana's doppelganger is even holding the
same curtain rod that's a callback
your typical joke in a TV comedy
requires very little space between the
setup in the punchline take the classic
Dick Van Dyke Show hey honey will you
bring me a handkerchief we going next
door
I can run back here blow my nose if
you've never seen the show before you're
still guaranteed a good laugh but
there's another set of much more
intricate jokes that are written
specifically for die-hard viewers they
are called callbacks running gags and
easter eggs so what's a callback exactly
a callback reference is a moment or a
joke that most likely happened in a
previous episode Seinfeld was one of the
first shows to employ callbacks pretty
regularly to use two famous Seinfeld
episodes one to set it up is the contest
where all the characters compete to see
who can go the longest without
masturbating so you're still master your
domain yes yes I am
George wins then later in the sucky
shirt episode that season five George is
trying to be a hand model the client
makes a reference to the previous hand
model not being quote master of his
domain he was not master of his domain
and George says not to worry about it
you don't have to worry about me
I want a contest if you're a casual
viewer you're not going to know what
that means but if you're a viewer who's
kind of stuck with Seinfeld a little bit
you know exactly what that means
callbacks can very easily turn into
running gags if they keep happening
again and again like no one knows what
the chicken sounds like on Arrested
Development chickens don't clap you're a
chicken kakuka tap CooCoo cacha
you're the chicken not me [ __ ] [ __ ] or
how Kenneth the page is an immortal
flesh vessel in 30 rock 1 the salt
jacket since 19 have it uh killed the
bird I've had for almost 60 years sure I
was legally dead for five minutes
who said I've been alive forever because
when I look into a mirror there's just a
white haze and in broad city a be always
happened to clean increasingly
disgusting things out of the gyms
bathroom gossip
yeah okay big ol clogged toilet in the
girls room we got another pube situation
in women's locker we could really use
some Abbi magic there's a pube situation
in the locker room that is unprecedented
somebody barked on an exercise ball and
then it bounced down two flights of
stairs so there's a bloody spill in your
speech to Joe but really there's a
bloody spill in the spin studio a good
example of how sort of intertwined
callbacks and running jokes can get is a
stylistic choice that broad city has
made for a couple moments when Abbi and
Ilana are disoriented or thrown off by a
piece of news oh my god she doesn't know
no one oh this is gonna be so rich a lot
of finds out that Abbi made out with a
friend of theirs
and Ilan has always wanted to make out
with Abby and has never gotten to so
this is a very personal blow to her this
is a direct callback shot-for-shot to a
moment when Abby misses a package
delivery that she's supposed to get for
her neighbor slash crush Jeremy are you
at this point that's a callback if they
use it again and keep using it that can
become a running joke
one of my favorite callbacks in broad
city actually begins in this episode
working girls when Abby has to track
down Jeremy's lost package here for his
distribution center is on North Brother
Island is that in New York I've never
even heard of that yes an East River
here were introduced to garel
ah
hello garol I'm not sure if I'm in the
right place Carroll was the keeper of
lost packages in other words an old lady
eating yogurt alone in a warehouse on
North Brother Island you would think
garol is just an amazingly cast one-hit
wonder
but fast forward 12 episodes and she's
the patron of a speakeasy that Abbie
performs at when she's blackout drunk
and she goes to a speakeasy and performs
as the sort of Liza Minnelli ish lounge
singer you a hot diggity dog and a
scallywag to boot with this very
exaggerated accent is so wonderful
especially because if you are a die-hard
broad city fan you might remember what
we will call an easter egg
Val town
how'd I not know that when Abbi gets
blackout drunk she becomes Val wait Val
let's rewind back to the second season
premiere the best part about this entire
moment is how Abby is just as confused
as we are at that point we'd never heard
of valve before it's a very elaborate
setup it's an amazing easter egg almost
every viewer will get a running gag more
attentive viewers will get callback only
diehards will get Easter eggs if a TV
show can pull off callbacks running gags
and Easter eggs it can really build out
a much more satisfying world one thing
you can count on broad city on is being
super surreal in the episode working
girls when Abby goes to North Brother
Island and she has this questions like
is that even a place and it actually is
a place it's in the middle of the East
River and its home to abandoned mental
institutions from the turn of the
century
Comedy Central is made of broad city map
of New York City and you can see North
Brother Island is located right here in
the East River and if you look closely
there's a little arrow pointing towards
Costco and one pointing towards Carol